all right today's lecture is brought to
you by an exciting new novel it's called
the one donkey solution I wrote it and I
am pushing it and it is available at
either of the book culture outlets or on
Amazon or for Kindle whatever you want
it is the novel that will tell you
pretty much everything there is to know
about the sexual and religious symbolism
of donkeys with respect to the coming of
the Messiah and president a pnina jawed
of Iran and President Obama are both
characters in the novel and the part of
the novel is actually narrated by the
donkey of the Messiah talking about what
he thought of Moses and what he thought
of Abraham and what he thought of Jesus
what he thought of Mohammed and so forth
this might not seem like a terribly
professional thing to do but when I was
interviewed for this job at Columbia in
1975 the chairman of department said
what will your next book book be I said
well it'll be a quantitative study of
conversion to Islam in the medieval
period is there what will your book be
after that I said well it'll be a a
reconsideration of the social history of
medieval Islam based upon the chronology
established in the book on conversion he
said and what will your book be after
that and I said it will be a study of
the sexual and religious symbolism of
donkeys so even though it took take it
was come out in the form of a novel it
is a scholarly enterprise I worked on
for 40 years and that was part of my
promise to the
the department when I applied for the
job here now that being said let us talk
about a chapter in the earth and its
people's dealing with basically Europe
from 1500 to 1700 you may have read the
chapter you may not read it yet but you
should read it before discussion
sections next week typically the
discussion sections will discuss the
chapter assigned in the preceding week
so you you read the chapter you hear the
lectures there will be some thought
questions emailed to you that will give
you sort of orienting things to might
you might think about before the
discussion sections in the following
week my starting point today is really
the sequencing of topics the world
history textbooks in general and indeed
most of the sort of single author
textbooks dealing with world history up
more or less fall into the pattern of
writing something about you know the
Mongol Empire and writing something
about the European Renaissance then
writing something about the maritime
expansion the age of exploration and
then shifting back to Europe to write
about the Reformation and what is called
early modern Europe and it's not really
clear that that is what one needs to do
the the entry of Europeans into the new
world which are we talking about next
week is particularly uncomfortable when
you think that you had two empires in
the new world the Inca and the Aztec
empires which we either talk about in
passing as part of the European voyages
of exploration and then they're referred
to as the conquest of Mexico and the
conquest of Peru that we devote an
entire chapter usually sometimes more to
the Roman Empire and it falls but it
doesn't get conquered the Empire own
Empire Falls will follow the Roman
Empire the Incas and the Aztecs get
conquered Rome is sort of like Humpty
Dumpty it fell off the wall and you know
there were barbarians but the barbarians
it's true they may have sacked Rome as
Alaric did or a below the hun but um but
that's not the same thing as conquering
well Roman dust falls and we're still
puzzled as to why whereas when it comes
to the new world empires you know they
got their their butts kicked by those
Europeans all thirteen or fourteen of
them and so they get conquered we do not
deal with the aftermath of that conquest
except to talk about what the Europeans
do after that
now structurally speaking the Europeans
are the barbarians attacking these
empires
when historians say Rome is a Empire and
civilization and it is assaulted by
barbarians we think of those barbarians
of the Vikings Li mad jars and so forth
as being less civilized when it comes to
the Aztecs and the Incas their empires
as described are described as the
empires of savages that they're the
barbarians and the Europeans are clearly
the the conquerors and somehow the the
greatness has been transferred from the
empire to the conquerors ah now I think
this is a very distorted and basically
Eurocentric way of approaching this but
it fits into the idea that the story of
world history since 1500 is at bottom
the story of the world that the
Europeans make and therefore those
people who do not contribute to the
story will gradually fall by the wayside
so the Aztecs and the Incas fall by the
wayside
eventually the the Indians and the
Chinese and others will fall by the
wayside until we simply have you know
what the West has has created
but in a period in the era of
globalization it's not you know
necessarily clear that the
accomplishment of the West has to be the
end of this story in a number of years
ago I compiled a book called the
Colombia history of the 20th century and
it was a thematic history there were
twenty chapters on different things that
had made the 20th century distinctive
but they were all themed attic things
for example there was a chapter on
socialism there was a chapter on
economic developments there's a chapter
of popular culture a chapter on
telecommunications a chapter on
transport a chapter on this and that
there was no chapter on World War one
and World War two or the Great
Depression or the Cold War because those
were episodes that are that happened in
the 20th century but in terms of
fundamentally altering the way people
live I felt that these themes were more
or more pertinent so I got a whole bunch
of people to write chapters and some of
them were pretty good and some of them
were not so good I wrote the
introduction and I wrote the conclusion
and the conclusion I said you know what
we think happened in the 20th century
now in 1999 will be completely rethought
in 2099 in the same way that people who
wrote about the 19th century in 1900 saw
the 19th century completely differently
than we see it now they didn't see it as
this period of you know racist
imperialist imposition of European
arrogance upon the whole globe
they saw it as a period of great
progress in which Europe had risen to
the pinnacle of civilization and offered
its gifts to the world whether they
wanted it or not
but now a hundred years later we looking
back back to the 19th century and we
talk about what was so terrible about
things the 19th century so my assumption
was that in at the beginning of the 22nd
century people will look back at the
20th century and see it very differently
so what I had in the conclusion of the
of the book was half dozen book
proposals sent to editors in 2099
proposing a history of the 20th century
from the perspective of a hundred years
in the future and like one of them would
say well since Asia has become the
dominant force in the entire world
obviously history of 20th century is a
history of the rise of Asia in which
case the European civil wars between
France and England and Germany and
America are really pretty damn trivial
because the important thing is China
Japan Korea that is what's happened in
the 21st century and therefore we have
to go back and reread the 20th century
in that perspective or an alternative
was you know the rise of to domination
of the Muslim world or the Union of
North and South America as an Anglo
Hispanic you know powerhouse in which
you know Brazil in the United States and
Canada and Mexico run the whole world
and so they see the 20th century very
much in terms of the the animosity
between English speakers and Spanish
speakers and the Western Hemisphere and
how that developed and how miraculously
it all disappeared
21st century as the dynamism of Western
Hemisphere economies took over in other
words I was simply trying to make a
point that the where you how you tell
the story is predicated on where you
were looking from and where you were
looking from changes with time so that
the the main master narratives a world
history as we get into the last 500
years tend to be rooted in the let's say
mid 20th century Western suprematism
that when Europe and America still were
unquestionably the you know where the
world was had gotten to and where I was
going to go and where perhaps the
biggest story was will it be socialist
communism or free enterprise that will
shape the future of the world
the idea that by the time we got to you
know the second decade of the 21st
century most young people would not know
what the Cold War was because it was
over and socialism communism were now
sort of historical antiques whereas
global domination of by one superpower
was now the norm that hadn't occurred to
anyone so when you look at a chapter
like this one an early modern Europe and
you see what has been selected to be in
the chapter and what has been deselected
you you have to ask yourself
is there any reason why anyone should
know who Henry the eighth was anymore or
is there any reason why Martin Luther
and John Calvin are the only Protestants
who really get mentioned that's at the
end of the eighth is there any reason to
know who Charles the fifth was because
the surprising thing not surprising to
me because I know who wrote the chapter
but the surprising thing I think in in
the context of thing about world history
is how much political standard Western
Civ has gotten into this chapter now
that's fine I mean we sometimes these
are wonderful stories but it also means
that there's an opportunity cost that
the things that you've put in have led
to things that you are leaving out so
I'm going to talk about some of things
have been left out with the idea that
when this chapter is rewritten for the
sixth edition because I think I'll be
rewriting it it may be revamped in a in
a strikingly different way for one thing
Europe between 15 and 1700 as it is
written in this chapter is basically
England France Italy Spain Eastern
Europe plays no significant role in the
chapter neither
southeastern Europe although wars with
the Ottoman Empire mentioned or
northeastern Europe although wars
between the polish-lithuanian
Confederation and Czarist Russia were
important at the time this is part of a
larger issue
that has to do with the entire arena of
historical development that encompasses
the Mediterranean Sea its Borderlands
and particularly Europe to the north if
you look at Islamic history you find
that they divide it the Muslims did the
historians did geographers did into the
west and the East the West was called
the Maghrib the East was called the
mushrik and they are strikingly
different areas so the West is North
Africa and Spain and the East is you
know Egypt you know Lebanon Syria Iraq
Iran so we have the mushrik and the
mother of the East and the West
interestingly the West tends to be the
land of wonder the land of legend land
where the history is almost completely
unreliable
whereas the East is what is solidly
known then you have Europe and we talk
about Western Europe and Eastern Europe
so we actually now have four quadrants
we have a eastern europe and south of
that and Eastern Islamic world then we
have a Western Europe south of that a
Western Islamic world and it doesn't
match the boundaries of of Europe
because for example Spain ah early on up
to 1492 would be in the Islamic West
you say well 1492 it is goes back into
the control of Christians but by that
time South Eastern Europe no Greece
Bulgaria Serbia those have come under
rural so now the southeast quadrant no
longer matches the division between
Europe and non Europe so we really have
a Europe that is primarily the northwest
and the Northeast but it doesn't even
coincide with Europe in the question of
what Europe is and why we should use the
term probably could be could be raised
in the same way that for the last 50
years people in my specialty have raised
a question of what is the middle east
what is it in the middle of it's not in
the middle of anything
where is the middle east does it include
this as include that an awful lot of now
ink has been wasted in that particular
unanswerable topic but you could raise
the same thing for Europe no what it
what is Europe whereas Europe is Europe
a geographical concept or is it
something that's constructed in
different times according to the to the
history that's going on so anyway in
this chapter it is really northwestern
Europe or whether the northwest quadrant
that includes northern Europe that that
gets the bulk of the attention when it
comes to humanism those humanists are
pretty much in that area when it comes
to scientific revolution by Georg Newton
was an Englishman and we should never
forget it
Galileo well anyway but Newton he was an
Englishman Tycho Brahe he was a Swede it
doesn't fit very well Copernicus was a
pole but let's stick with Newton because
after all he's English so we write a lot
about Newton we leave some of these
other people out what would you gain if
you included some of this other stuff
well
since a big part of this story is the
conflict between Protestants and
Catholics and we more or less portray
the period after Martin Luther's posting
of his theses on the cathedral door at
Wittenberg we more or less cast out as a
hundred years of a war between
Protestants and Catholics what would you
get if you included some other part of
Europe well let us say you go to 1570 to
1570 to is though which we do not
mention the chapter although we could
have it's the st. Bartholomew's Day
Massacre that was when the either the
royal family of France or equally highly
placed individuals probably the
Secretary of Defense arranged to kill
all of the Huguenots leaders all the
Protestant leaders they failed to kill
the primary one admiral Collini but they
managed to kill thousands of others in a
great slaughter in the streets and the
Saint Bartholomew's Day Massacre marked
pretty much the end of of dynamic
Protestantism in France and so it's a
famous a famous event that's 1572 1573
is the the warsaw confederation that was
a document that was drawn up in europe's
largest country which was a
confederation of poland and lithuania
that had one of the largest populations
in Europe and it was a document that was
knowledgeable of what had happened in
France and the Saint part of the brothel
news Day Massacre
and what is is a document in which all
of the nobles of Poland and Lithuania
agree that there should be absolutely
real oohed religious freedom for both
commoners amble and the and nobility and
that there should be no religious test
for who rules there should be no
religious discrimination of any kind
and indeed Poland becomes for it doesn't
last but for a century or so
Poland becomes the model of religious
toleration it also becomes the first
constitutional monarchy by Constitution
they actually formally create a
constitution very late in the game in
the late 1700s but from the late 1500s
on they have a system by which the king
is elected the king is elected by the
nobles but Poland Lithuania had more
Nobles than any other part of Europe 10%
of the population were counted as the
nobility and they had to elect who is
going to be king so when a king died you
would have candidates like the French
King would say I want my brother to be
king of Poland or the Russian Tsar would
say I want to be king of Poland or
Hungarian Kings I want to be king of
home and you would have basically you
know debates where the candidates to be
king would have to sell their their
views to the other nobles and the
curious thing was that the vote had to
be unanimous
so the the polling lasted for months and
then enemy candidates would show up at
the place where the nobles were all
assembled and
with an army and say you know I want to
be I want to be king and I happen to
have four hundred heavily armed soldiers
who also think I should be king so one
is that's yeah but I have five hundred
heavily armed so so they would
occasionally you know get into brawls
people he killed fights a breakout but
it actually worked they elected Kings
and the Kings did not impose their
religion so Poland in the late 1500s
unlike anywhere else in Europe had
Catholics Catholics hated this deal they
had probably 20 or so different
varieties of Protestants because they're
Protestants you know like mushrooms they
just popped out in all sorts of forms
they had Jews the Jews were completely
part of the whole deal at that time not
what they were in the nineteenth century
and they had Muslims you had Muslims who
were subjects of the Polish King living
in Poland and others who were allies of
the Polish monarchy during one or
another of the various wars that they
had to this day in Lithuania there is a
population of Muslims that is still
remaining from that era
because the idea that Islam and
Christianity were necessarily hostile to
one another that was the crusading
notion which was basically a Western
European notion in Eastern Europe
Muslims were not by definition the enemy
and when you look for example at the
history of Ivan the fourth Ivan the
Terrible in Russia then the middle of
the 1500s a number of wars that he
participates in he has Muslim allies
and Muslims can be in Moscow and have a
mosque I mean it's it just isn't the big
deal in the east of the northeast
quadrant that it is in the northwest
now we've inherited the idea that the
Northwest is our model and yet if we
were to visualize a world in which
Muslims and Christians actually got
along or let's say Muslims and post
Christians maybe we should have we
should talk about this history that says
there was a time when when tolerance and
acceptance were normal between Muslims
and Christians and we should stick this
into the history book and perhaps have a
few paragraphs left about Crusaders and
Saracens beating up on each other and
earlier in earlier episodes because one
of the assumptions about any world
history textbook is is you know what is
the utility of knowing this body of
knowledge as opposed to you know some
other body of knowledge so I think
there's a there's a fundamental
rethinking that needs to go into a
chapter like this that partly is just a
matter of diversifying the geography but
partly it's a matter of asking what do
we need to know today about Europe
however you're defining it and events
that took place between 1500 and 1700
which we have now labeled early modern
events how early modern is an extremely
slippery term because it anticipates
that modern is just waiting in the wings
to come on and therefore what you should
write about are those things that will
be part of the modern but are the wives
of Henry
the eighth part of the moderate well of
course you know the tutor series on HBO
makes them part of the modern but aside
from things like that do we need to know
that it's not clear that we do the
pressure of competing textbooks if
everybody else mentions hundred the
eighth we'll probably have to as well
but nevertheless that's a different
consideration the opportunity cost of
talking about the standard Western Civ
things for Northwest Europe in this
period extends not only to issues of
religious and political importance such
as what I mentioned about Poland
Lithuania but it also gets into the
theme of the book now as I said we have
two themes dominance and diversity is
one okay Dominus adversity really works
for Protestants and Catholics each one
wants to dominate the other and the
other constitutes diversity I suppose in
some sense nevertheless the theme of
Technology and the environment
it's is way way way under played for
this particular period in ways that
prevent us from seeing how Europe in
this period for prefigures not the
political or the cultural shape of
today's world but more of the the
technologies that are taken for granted
today and as with so many things in
technology a lot of this has to do with
war and I'm separating here the history
of science which is talked about and yet
it's not clear how important the history
of science is quite frankly I mean
Kopernik you know let's say Galileo
could see mountains on the moon but if
it had been dark every night with a
cloud cover
would it have made much difference
whether you could see the moon or not I
mean people are going to still leave
their lives I'm not sure astronomy is
anywhere near as important as the
historians of science seem to think it
is but war clearly is an important
technology not least because Europe
becomes and particularly from this
period onward probably the most warlike
area and the entire globe and if you're
going to talk about European
exceptionalism and what is special about
Europe you're probably going to say they
kill each other more than anybody else
does and what we get to with the
European Union now here we have half a
century 60 years of not killing each
other
longest period of peace in Europe since
August us of the beginning of the Roman
Empire you know Europeans just aren't
used to this and I think they're not
reacting very well but so what's
happening in the area of war because
that is for Europe and for America so
much the the point of genesis of new
technologies or new or new uses of
technology there is a convention by
which we call Muslim empires of this
period the Ottomans the moguls the
Safavid so I'll talk about them in a
couple of weeks we call them gunpowder
empires it's a bad convention I will not
use it myself I do not endorse it it's
based on on a book somebody wrote that
fundamentally based on a misreading of a
chronicle and it's just nonsense but it
does point out that gunpowder becomes
very important in this period well
actually gunpowder is important 200
years earlier before 1500 it's just that
the way in which gunpowder weapons
develop changes the nature of warfare in
the 1500s and into the 1600s in ways
that have somewhat less than obvious
implications the in the period of the
Crusades going back to the to the 12th
century the European aristocracy were
Knights the male's they wore armor they
rode horses they carried a shield they
carried a lance
they carried a sword or a battle-axe and
they beat up on each other whenever
whenever they could
it's sort of a game of Thrones is a good
portrayal of it if you follow the
television i watch the knights disappear
and this is the time when they disappear
in the course of the 1500s everyone sort
of grants that well it was gunpowder
that made the Knights less and less
relevant but exactly how did that happen
because you know a guy wearing a thick
metal costume riding down on you on a
big heavy horse with the Lance is going
to be scary no matter what it is I mean
if you have a gun you say I miss my god
yeah I'm dead
but but the fact of matter is for what
you had at this time in in the Ottoman
Empire was the development of
a infantry units called Janissaries and
i'll talk about them in a couple of
weeks that were armed with very heavy
Harco buses that were guns that were so
heavy that you know you held it to your
shoulder and then i don't have a stand
in front to hold up the front end
because it was just too heavy you
couldn't ride a horse and fire one but
steadily the guns became lighter and
lighter and what you had developing in
the 1500s in europe was the idea that
you can have a soldier who would carry
two pistols this was the idea of a of a
quail I see a clear glass was a
breastplate something covered the chest
and the back and the first quickness
ea's would wear a helmet a metal
breastplate a metal black back plate and
metal above the knee on their legs in
front but they would sit on a horse I
wouldn't have any metal on their butt
and the lower below the knee they would
where they would long boots by 1600
there the armor is becoming less and
less and less because they need to move
faster and they're heavy and the armor
isn't as I protect you in that much so
gradually it becomes simply a a
breastplate and a back plate and maybe
some kind of a helmet they carry two
pistols and they develop a technique
known as the cow heel kya kool where
they ride their horse toward the enemy
line they have the horse shy to the left
and then they shoot with a right hand
pistol then they have the horse shy to
the right they shoot with their left
hand pistol
and then they pivot around and go back
and the next tier comes up and shoots
their pistols dramatically different
from what a knight does the night is is
galloping forward in order to make
contact whereas these quail CAS and
there are other formations that did the
same thing dragoons for example they
were driving they were riding forward to
close distance on the enemy to get
within firing distance quickly fire and
then retreat so the nobility of of you
know killing someone no with a club
right up close that that nobility was
being diminished and these people who
are firing pistols were not nobles they
were more or less an elevated lower
level of the army rather than the
nobility coming down to - to this this
low leg of activity shortly thereafter
by the time you get to the to the 18th
century or the well into the 17th
century you start to have Musketeers
because the musket is a new type of long
weapon that is much more accurate than
these pistols it was very questionable
by there anyone ever hit anything with
these pistols because the pistols were
extremely inaccurate in those days a
pistol would often sort of no you know
go out at the end like a trumpet or
something and the ball that it fired to
go down the barrel bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce and go out in some
direction or other but the idea that it
would go in a straight line was just
wishful thinking
so some armies didn't believe in this
sort of thing but a lot of them did so
during these wars of religion you had a
change in technology that pushed in the
direction of horse riders carrying
firearms against infantry formations
that
very long Spears called pikes not like
17 feet long so that the person in the
front row of pikes will be kneeling on
the ground and holding a spike out and
an angle anchored under the ground the
one behind him when holding his pike
straightforward going over his shoulder
and so forth and the idea was that if
the horse has come too close they'll hit
the Pikes and they will they will shy
away so you were going from having
warfare conceptualized as you know face
to face bludgeoning one another with
axes and swords and hammers and so forth
to more of a standoff thang where you
don't necessarily presume that you were
going to get into that final
hand-to-hand combat although if you had
one pike force against another then you
would have what was on his push of pikes
where the two groups or just push it
each other and see which one could push
harder and kill more but all of this
began to diminish the role of the night
it was no longer and don't longer have
the nobility that it had before Knights
continue to exist
their armor became increasingly
ceremonial used for for jousts or for
parading cows ting armor for example was
often made with without the flexibility
to actually be used in battle because
Johnston became a separate activity that
had derived from warfare but was no
longer part of the warfare now what did
it mean if the aristocracy were no
longer defining themselves as being
Knights prepared to ride into battle
with Lance and armor and strike against
the enemy Oh for one thing it made
horseback riding less of a marker of
social status than it had been for the
thousand years prior to this time in
other words between the time of the
decline of the chariot and that was in
last year's course and the rise of the
gunpowder horse born gunpowder the the
night was a mounted armored warrior and
a man who did not ride a horse really
couldn't be thought of as a nobleman the
best example of this and I mentioned
this last year has nobody will recall
was the famous old French poem by Katie
andit waa from the 12th century called
the knight of the cart in that's it's an
Arthurian story and in the story of the
knight of the cart Queen Guinevere is
kidnapped by an evil person so the call
goes out to the knights of the round
table who will go and we recover Queen
Guinevere from this evil captivity and a
number of knights sort of leap out and
run out down their horses and head off
to rescue Guinevere among them is
Lancelot
Lancelot not only is doing it for for
the Offor honor but because he's
personally crazy mad in love with
Guinevere he gets into a fracas on his
way to rescue her and he loses his horse
now he's so eager to find her that when
a farmer comes by with a cart he hops on
the cart and rides off to pursue his
quest he now becomes known as the knight
of the cart the knight who
had who shamed himself by sitting in a
vehicle because for a nobleman to ride
in a cart was a source of profound shame
because carts in that period in 12th
century 13th century 14th century carts
were farmers vehicles they are used for
crops and bringing in goods you know
from the village and for a nobleman to
get in a cart was simply wrong and it
was a source of shame it wasn't just
wrong in the abstract but it made you
notorious for having having shamed your
entire status as a knight so Lancelot
becomes the knight of the cart and it's
a source of shame now you get to the end
of knighthood and what happens men are
able to ride in vehicles you think well
surely they can always write in vehicles
well of course they could if they were
very old like me or if they were ill or
if they were a divinely ordained king
they might write in a vehicle but
basically vehicles were for farmers and
women and for a man to get in a vehicle
say prior to 1500 in Western Europe was
simply was simply wrong now oddly enough
starting around 1400 there had been
dramatic changes in the nature of
vehicles and those changes don't get
written about because they occurred in
Hungary instead of in Western Europe but
in Hungary you had invented a kind of
vehicle
called a coach which is from a Hungarian
word play a place named City of coach
and then this developed that not
directly but this becomes Express war in
English by the word carriage so
carriages come into being in the fifth
in the 1400s in Eastern Europe
interestingly they also get used away
guns get used for warfare in Eastern
Europe at this time and the notion of
circling the wagons where you have a
some wagons that you take to battle and
then you arrange them a circle or a
square and you fight from the protection
of the wagons that concept originated in
the late 1300s with the followers of the
proud early true proto Protestant leader
yon who's the hussite wars where they
had circling the wagons and in Poland
and Hungary from that time on of you you
know having your military depend upon
basically a portable fort consisting of
a circle of wagons becomes a standard
tactic these are called loggers or
they're called pay boars they're various
terms for them the old you know
eventually comes to be used in South
Africa and the Boer War it's used in
America for the pioneers to circle the
wagons against the attacking Indians so
forth and so on
this is when that tactic originates you
circle the wagons and use get either in
the wagons are behind the wagons with
your firearm you shoot in between once
you get cannon you can have the cannon
shoot from between the wagons and this
is the sort of portable fortress it's
not used in Western Europe so that part
the military part of it does not carry
over into Western Europe
but the the other technical developments
do and I'm not going to get into detail
because I'm teaching a seminar in the
history will vehicles that nobody is
attending and if anyone's go to
undergraduate senior seminar on the
history of wheel transport I've lots of
room in the seminar but this is when you
have brakes invented and steering
mechanisms and suspension and the
concept of the separation between body
and chassis essentially you you go from
a very primitive kind of vehicle circa
ten hundred or eleven hundred by fifteen
hundred you have a pretty fancy
and technically developed vehicle but in
fifteen hundred it still isn't dignified
for a man to ride of that vehicle so in
Eastern Europe you get carriages that
high-status man will ride in but not in
Western Europe uh Queen Elizabeth
when she went from one place to another
the goods that she carried with her for
her entourage and her upkeep and so
forth would fill a couple of hundred
carts two-wheeled baggage vehicles but
she would ride on a horse and then she
then there was a nobleman in England in
the middle of the 1500s who ordered a
carriage to be built in Holland and
imported into England and then Queen
Elizabeth thought I could have one of
those in fact I could have three of
those and so she got carriages and then
lo and behold by the early 1600s
London was crammed with carriages it is
absolutely extraordinary the growth of
the carriage industry parallels the
motorcar
you know explosion of the early 20th
century and the steam railroad explosion
of the early 19th century that you went
from having almost all passenger
transport being by horseback to having
it be increasingly by carriage Oh
this revolution and it's interesting yet
we when we get to to the Industrial
Revolution will talk about how important
railroads are so you have steel for the
rails and steel for the steam engines or
we'll talk about how important motorcars
are to industrialization but in fact the
carriage industry with all of its
different particular designs of vehicles
prefigures everything it's going to
happen later
and yet it's left out of world history
all right you don't have to put in
everything in world history but what are
the implications of the carriage
industry well let's say in the
development of steering but supposing on
a four wheel wagon if you want to turn
that wagon you have a problem because
the wheel is going to run into the bed
of the wagon so even if you're pivoting
the front axle you can only pivot it
maybe five degrees depending on how wide
the axle is before it hits the the edge
of the wagon at the edge of the of the
wagon bed that's known as a full lock
position when the wheel comes in contact
with the with wagon bed however if you
did I like this and you make your front
wheel of a small diameter then you can
pivot the front axle and the wheel will
go underneath the bed of the wagon and
so one of the clear things that you look
at in images of will transport from the
14th century onward is what is the
relative size of the back wheels and the
front wheels the front wheels are
noticeably smaller it means that their
steering the thing whereas if the wheels
are of exactly the same size and clearly
interfering with the bed of the of the
four-wheel vehicle that it means that
they don't have a steering so
which means it can't use it in a city
because if you can't steer it a
four-wheel vehicle you know it's sort of
like those shopping carts that have one
or two frozen wheels you're trying to
turn it and you just can't do it fine
you pick them thing up and shove it over
because turning a four-wheel vehicle if
the way if you can't steer it is just
extremely slow you wear it in a very
very large turning radius
so prior to steering you couldn't have a
carriage in town because you couldn't
turn it barn out a carriage you're going
to have a four wheeled passenger vehicle
in town because you couldn't turn it the
towns were not big enough to have space
to turn the vehicle and you couldn't
really have it in the country very well
because there were no paved roads and
that becomes a problem here the smaller
the diameter of the wheel the smoother
the road has to be because the ability
of the wheel to simply go over a rough
surface is proportional to the size of
the pail it's like you know
rollerblading on a brick street or a
cross-country through a forest is
something you don't usually do because
the wheels are too small and yet you
could have a mountain bike and go across
country because the wheel is so much
bigger so when they start to steer it
then they reduce the size of the front
wheel and then they have to improve the
surface of the of the road that the
vehicle goes on so now in the 1600s
you're starting to get cities in Western
Europe earlier in Eastern Europe that
have passenger vehicles in it and are
beginning to have paved streets they're
becoming more like a city that we would
identify you go back to say to
Renaissance art
and look at pictures of Rome and other
places and you say well this is really
kind of open country studded with ruins
of Roman this of that but there are no
roads or just sort of tracks through
this ruin then now you begin to say well
a city needs to have a layout of streets
because there are vehicles that have to
that have to pass through those streets
and so you have to consider what is
paving now how do you pay the street in
a way that that actually works history
of pavement is really interesting and
I'm not going to go into it I have
preparing for the seminar I've learned
more about the detailed history of
asphalt and I have ever thought that I
would know and I've been trying to
forget it
ever since I read the book but it's but
it is very important because your your
vehicle technology and you're paving
technology are moving along parallel the
better the lighter the more efficient
your vehicles the more you need a better
pavement so now you're beginning to have
a substantially greater separation
between life in the city and life in the
countryside the countryside has mud
right down to let's say the middle of
the nineteenth century I think that at
the time of World War one the United
States had something like 20,000 miles
of paved road outside of cities
otherwise we simply don't have paved
roads in the United States that far into
the 20th century and if it rained that
meant you had mud and it rains all the
time and you're upsetting this just it's
really the bud zone where where every
account of people trying to go
cross-country and wheeled vehicles in
the 1600s is just
studded with these terrible stories of
you know being mired down to the
floorboards and in mud
you have monarchs who are travelling by
carriage from one major city in their
realm to another who tip over several
times in the course of the trip because
the roads are so incredibly bad so so
the life of the city is now separating
in a Technol in a technological fashion
from the life of the country you can get
around the city but it's very hard to
get anywhere outside the city not only
that but now the cities can grow in size
prior to having the vehicles so readily
at hand in the city you could ride a
horse of course if you had one but but
largely these cities were pedestrian
scale now you can beg to begin to
develop things on the outskirts of the
city because you have carriages but
perhaps as important as any of these
things because this is mostly
technological innovation that is
utilized by the by the elite by the
noble class what you have is the idea
that your ride tells people who you are
you see somebody's carriage at all oh
that's the Duke of Norfolk because I'd
recognise his carriage because see if
you're a knight you had your coat of
arms on your on your shield or your
Squire carried a banner that would bear
your device but now you can put it on
the side of your carriage and you start
to have major competition within the
elite to have fancier and fancier
vehicles
they're not driving the vehicles you
hire servants to drive the vehicles
although by the 19th century they start
to drive the vehicles but you put your
coat of arms on the vehicle and you have
your servants who are driving and caring
for the horses where the colors that are
appropriate to your to your house so
you're getting a level of symbolic
competition that is new but one that
sticks with us I mean the idea of social
competition to taking the form of what
do you ride in what do you drive begins
now in the 1600s and continues down down
to the present day so it's it is a
social and status an essentially popular
culture outcome that really begins with
changes in in the way you use gunpowder
on the battlefield because the Knights
could not have written in in a vehicle
200 years earlier but now they can and
now they compete well how do they
compete you can you know at the tail end
of knighthood you can compete by
jousting but as you move along you can
compete by racing your vehicles
NASCAR essentially becomes a conceptual
possibility starting in the 1600s so
when I rewrite this chapter there's
going to be a lot about technological
change and environment that that's not
there now
because these are things that not only
happen them but have had long-lasting
effects in shaping not simply later
European society or American society but
actually world society the whole notion
of of highway systems of roads being an
important point of definition in what
constitutes a culture you know where do
your highways go let's say you have a
national you know in the 1500s at the
end of the Wars of Religion you had a
what political scientists think of as
the birth of the nation-state
the idea that instead of having a kind
of vague and poorly defined frontier
between two different political entities
that are radiating out from some capital
city or some palace you get the idea
that the states will border one another
in a specifically defined fashion with
border posts and guards and so forth and
you will go from one state to another at
a crossing point and that makes a great
deal of sense political science as a as
a great turning point in world history
but but it also of course has great
implications for for something like
transportation once you decide that you
have a state then how do you build your
roads do you connect them across the
border where you keep them within your
country
do you use your road system to make your
provincial outlying areas more easily
contacted by the capital or do you use
them for some other purpose this is not
happening yet by the 1600s but it
eventually happens that the the road
networks and the railroad networks
become the become the part of the
defining character of of the
nation-state one thing I should point
out here is that these four wheeled
vehicles the carriages that were
primitive in design before 1400 but
become more and more sophisticated until
they become suitable for elite private
use use these four wheeled vehicles
don't exist anywhere else in the world
at that time there are no four-wheel
vehicles in China
no four-wheel vehicles in India no
four-wheel vehicles in Japan no vehicles
at all in the Middle East and in most of
the provincial of most of the areas that
become part of the European colonial
world for example Latin America you
don't have any four-wheel vehicles the
reason for this is because for wheeled
vehicles don't make much sense you can't
steer them without a lot of technical
complication but even more if you every
axle you add multiplies the amount of
friction you have so the more wheels you
have the harder it is to pull
so that's your most of history if you
had a fixed source of power such as a
pair of oxen or a pair of horses
if they were pulling a four-wheel
vehicles they would be able to pull less
weight than if they were pulling a
two-wheeled vehicle so other parts of
the world do about four wheeled vehicles
and said we don't need them we want two
wheeled vehicles now if it was a
ceremonial vehicle at something else for
example the great movable temple in
eastern India known as the juggernaut
which was before the Marvel Comics
invented a character named juggernaut
the juggernaut is was a huge mammoth
temple on wheels that could could only
go straight it couldn't be turned and if
you fell in front of it or if you read a
bowtie and you're three years old in
front of it you would be crushed by the
juggernaut the only image I've been able
to find of the of the wheel assembly of
a juggernaut was interesting it had 18
wheels no two of them on the same axle
each one on a separate axle and so you
do get ceremonial vehicles that will be
more than carts with any kind of
economic efficiency calls for
two-wheeled cart until you get to these
developments trade 1,400 and 1,600 that
develop steering brakes suspension and
things like that now the reason this is
important is that all modern Motor
Transport assumes a four-wheeled format
with the exception of motorcycles a few
other odd vehicles but basically the
idea is that you take a carriage and you
put you take away the horses and the
oxen and you put an engine on it you how
do you rate the engine by horsepower
because it's saying the place of the
horses
it's very good for traffic because it's
is exactly half the length of the of the
horse-drawn vehicle in other words don't
hear your horses and once you take away
the horses now you have twice as much
room on the street but that's quickly
filled up because everybody gets it gets
the vehicle so four wheeled vehicles are
the vision of the future in in the
European early modern period that nobody
has recognized because nobody's asked
the question of why did no one else have
four wheeled vehicles and this is a
puzzle I believe that the answer is that
at least this is judging from images of
four wheeled vehicles in the Roman
Empire and in medieval sources there
aren't many images then you have
probably a dozen or twenty or so and
they almost all show that they're
passenger vehicles not cargo vehicles
and they carry women it's because the
man won't ride in the vehicle the van
will ride the horse alongside difficult
he won't ride in the vehicle and the
women are always depicted only ones I've
seen as women of high status in other
words a queen and her retinue a princess
and her maidens upper-class women so
that introduces the question of how do
people move classy women in different
parts of the world you know you can't
say you know princess honey you know
take a horse over to the neighbors and
borrow a crown because she's going to be
waylaid and raped and that'll be the end
of your dynasty so you say you go over
and borrow a crown and I'll send 12-man
along
with you to keep you from being waylaid
and rape it is interesting that in
Thomas More's utopia
so 14th century work he says that when
the citizens of utopia go from one town
to another on some sort of official
errand ah they are issued a vehicle by
the town to to carry them on their
embassy unless they have no women with
them in which case they were ride their
horses because the only reason you would
ever have a vehicle is if you have to
move a woman of high status someplace
now you could move her in a sedan chair
this was you know you have eight men
carrying a chair in the shoulder and a
woman in her and her girlfriend can be
sitting inside and you can be carried
around and that's what they did in China
hazard in Japan in fact the Meiji
Emperor who's associated with
modernization of Japan never went
anywhere in Japan in a wheeled vehicle
he was carried in a sedan chair
everywhere he went throughout his life
but but basically high status women are
hard to to transport so what you get is
in most parts of the world the women are
confined at home they're kept in the
home they don't move and the men move
and if they need sex while they're
traveling they bring a boy that's what
boys are for so we have all sorts of
evidence of this where you know the
night in a squire I mean please how many
of these Squires simply shined the Arbor
and ill-fed the horses you know
you know you might find a trollop and a
wayside in but if you weren't that lucky
there's always a squire but if you so so
in most parts of the world women are
secluded Europe does not seclude its
women
so Europe kept an absolute amount
obsolete but an inefficient form of
transport that could not be used in the
city primarily the purpose of carrying
high status women across the countryside
so it turns out that the sort of a
primitive character of European society
that chose to treat high status women
differently than other societies laid
the groundwork for technological
developments that give Europe a unique
set of technical developments that lead
to Europe becoming the place where
modern Motor Transport whether by steam
or by internal combustion engine where
they develop so it's one of those issues
where the history of gender gets
overlapped with history of
transportation and gets into the entire
history of a vehicular culture so that
is the aspect of technology in the
environment that I hope to introduce
this chapter but at what cost
now I count how many words is going to
take me to explain this it's only taken
me an hour to do it today but supposing
I only have 250 words what do I take out
I'm afraid Henry the eighth's may have
to go I hate to say it but now Henry's
perhaps had his had his moment and I've
had mine so that's the end of today's
lecture
you